hallo
herzlich willkommen in unserer torten
welt von mir und ich wir haben heute
richtig lust auf einen leckeren kuchen
wir wollen aber den backofen nicht
einschalten und deswegen gibt es einen
kuchen aus dem kühlschrank also
praktisch einen not wakeskate die basis
dafür ist einfach so ein brösel boden
dann kommt eine leckere philadelphia
creme oben drauf und das ganze
aromatisieren wir heute mit etwas
pfefferminze und am ende des videos
möchte ich euch noch auf eine aktion
hinweisen
denn dann gibt es wieder ein super
tolles gewinnspiel aber das kommt später
ich lasse euch noch ein bisschen
neugierig dasitzen und zeigt euch
einfach mal kurz die zutaten also ich
habe hier ein paar kekse und zwar nehme
ich da gern vollkornkekse ihr könnt aber
auch zum beispiel löffelbiskuits nehmen
einfach 100 gramm
dann habe ich hier 125 gramm butter 50
gramm mandeln gehackte 50 beim schopfe
drops für die creme brauchen wir 400
gramm frischkäse oder nehme ich gern
philadelphia 203 schlagsahne eine halbe
zitrone davon den saft ich habe hier 100
gramm puderzucker und später eben noch
ein bisschen pfefferminze und essig
alkoholfrei dann noch etwas sahne steif
mittel und ein paar himbeeren die samira
davids zuerst die vollkornkekse einfach
mal in so eine tüte machen einfach
einstecken
und dann gleich zerbröseln und ich gebe
schon mal die butter in kleine topf die
cella sich hier drin krabbelstuben und
die mandeln gebe ich in der pfanne die
rostig ganz ohne fett einfach ein
bisschen an dann haben sie ein besseres
aroma
und jetzt zerkleinern wir das einfach
mit so einem nudelholz des dachs
schumacher
dann geben wir da noch die gerösteten
mandeln mit dazu
und die heiße butter und dann verrückt
ist schön mit einem löffel oder mit
tauber zum beispiel das ist eine schöne
im affekt sondern richtig klebrigen
jetzt gebe ich hier noch diese schoko
trotz mit rein dann haben nämlich so
schönen schokoladigen boden
es klingt gut oder
und jetzt gebe ich immer so etwa ein
esslöffel voll in so kleinen förmchen
und da auch ganz normale des erringen
ich hab halt welche mit so einem boden
unten drin
die sind ganz praktisch
und dann drücke ich das einfach mit so
einem esslöffel schön flach fällt ihr
keine dessert förmchen und auch nicht
diese dessert schildchen ab könnte das
auch in einem glas machen also der ist
halt ein glas dessert was ihr später
dann nicht mehr raus stürzen könnt aber
dann ist auch ein hübsches löffel dass
er was man einfach aus dem glashaus
geben kann und ich mach das jetzt ganz
kurz und stellt die förmchen dann ganz
kurz kalt entweder für 15 minuten in den
kühlschrank oder für etwa zehn minuten
ins gefrierfach
die förmchen stets kalt und ich kann
jetzt schon mal die creme vorbereiten
hab ich hier meine schlagsahne und
schlagt die schon mal steigt während
samira mir noch ein paar hinschaut
da gebe ich noch sommerparty dazu also
die soziale stadt mittels maus mehr alle
hin wenn du
die sahne habe ich jetzt kurz kühl
gestellt weil es bei mir in der küche
ziemlich warm ist und jetzt bereite ich
hier den frischkäse noch vor so einfach
in eine schüssel groß genug dass man
über das radl vier schön verrühren kann
dann gebe ich da den puderzucker mit
rein
ein spritzer zitronensaft graz wo für
den geschmack
es reicht schon und dann kommt da
nämlich dieser familie rupp mit rein
ihr könnt im prinzip wenn jetzt keine
pfefferminze mögt auch ganz was anderes
neben himbeer kokos ganz egal da gibt es
ganz verschiedene sorten und ganz
verschiedene geschmacksrichtungen und
ich habe mich jetzt für die pfefferminze
entschieden weil die einfach richtig
frisch schmeckt
wenn niedriger stufe einmal verrühren
und auch hier gebe ich ein bisschen sein
apartment rein damit schön fest wird
jetzt kann ich hier noch die sahne
unterheben und dann stelle ich die scram
noch mal ganz kurz kühl bis einfach der
brösel boden richtig bestes und dann
kann man gleich das törtchen
zusammensetzen
der brüssel wurden ist jetzt schön kalt
und jetzt kann ich hier erst mal die
himbeeren rein schichten und dann kommt
da die leckere krämer
einfach schön an den rand legen denn
später wenn die gewinne die törtchen aus
den völkchen rauskommt sieht man die
schön vor allem wir nehmen auch in einem
glas macht wenn ich es immer toll wenn
die häme bernd schönemann sind und dann
einfach in wissel ausführen
und jetzt nehme ich mir die pfefferminz
creme und würdet ihr ihnen ein weg
spritzbeutel dann habe ich einfach
leichter das gleich in die förmchen
einzufüllen vor allem wenig dass auch in
den gläschen macht könnte vielen
sauberer arbeiten
aber natürlich geht es auch mit einem
ganz normale kleine löffel dauert nur
ein bisschen länger
der kunden einfach nur spitze
wegschneiden oben den verschluss immer
schön drehen damit hinten nicht raus
gewählt und dann die förmchen damit
füllen
dann klopfe ich mir ein bisschen sind
das sicher manchmal viele luftlöcher
sind und die krebs oder überall rein
aber die viel luftlöcher
dem gleichzeitig auch als body lotion
und jetzt streiche ich das grab mit
seiner kleinen winkel palette noch ein
bisschen flood damit die oberfläche auch
schön aussieht muss man nicht machen
kann man machen wenn man lust drauf hat
und dann stelle ich die noch mal kurz
kühl und dann können wir sie gleich
fertig stellen
meine törtchen sind jetzt schön kalt und
im prinzip auch schon fertig aber ich
werde jetzt noch ein bisschen dekorieren
damit sie noch schöner werden und zwar
bekommen die von bei mir jetzt gleich
noch einen schoko rand aber zuerst nehme
ich jetzt hier mal die pfötchen raus
kann man ganz leicht von unten nach oben
drücken
und weil die jetzt so eben nett so
hübsch aussehen kriegen sie noch diesen
hübschen schoko aber erst nach unten
noch boden ablösen
dann setze ich sie auf einen teller
jetzt habe ich hier einfach ein bisschen
geschmolzene kuvertüre der mich jetzt
temperiert auf 28 grad
und die gebe ich mir jetzt hier auf so
buck papierstreifen die habe ich brauche
zurechtgeschnitten und die lege ich dann
jetzt gleich außen rum
ich habe einfach aus gemessen wie bereit
oder wie lange ebenda streifen sein muss
um damit um die taten drumherum passt
muss auch nicht ganz exakt sein also es
kann auch ein bisschen überlappen das
kriegt man später wieder weg
jetzt mache ich erstmal vier und dann
später die nächsten 4
jetzt könnte es ganz einfach mit mobbing
die palette oder mit einem löffel
verstreichen
jetzt habe ich hier auf dem eis vielfach
john kyl akku damit er jetzt nicht so
dreckig wird lediglich 13 küchentuch
drauf und legt es ganz kurz drüber bevor
es auf meint örtchen kommt denn dann
wird es einfach schon mal so ein
bisschen fest und läuft nicht so schnell
der zeit verstreichen als die anderen
und wenn es dann beginnt ein bisschen
fester zu werden nehme ich jetzt diesen
show cooking legen um das törtchen auf
dann einfach ankleben
das macht jetzt auch nichts wenn das
papier so ein bisschen überlebt das
schneiden wir zugleich einfach
jetzt ist die schokolade fest ich hatte
es so etwas eine minute im kühlschrank
jetzt kann ich das backpapier abziehen
ganz vorsichtig und dann wird mir davon
übergang kommen mütter mit einem messer
so ein bisschen ein rätsel
und dann geradezu den rest abziehen dann
immer fluss nehme ich jetzt hier runter
wer möchte kann jetzt oben die
schokolade noch ein bisschen abbrechen
dass er einfach ein regelmäßiger
aussieht je nachdem wie ihr das halt
haben wollt ich gebe auf jeden fall noch
ein tröpfchen von dem sirup von
pfefferminz sirup mitreisen
dann so eine aufgeschnittene schokolade
mit pfefferminz innen drin
kein star sein
so sehe jetzt meine fertigen törtchen
aus und die kann man jetzt ganz einfach
mit einem löffel raus löffeln oder auch
mit einer gabel denn dieser brösel boden
ist ein bisschen fester auf jeden fall
sind sie ziemlich einfach in der
herstellung sehr schnell gemacht und
markante hat auch gut vorbereiten und
wenn ihr dieses rezept nach machen wollt
dann geht einfach auf meinen blog auf
sallys - blog.de da gibt es noch mal die
genauen mengenangaben und die und die
beschreibung wie es eben geht
und jetzt möchte ich noch auf dieses
gewinnspiel zu sprechen kommen was sich
schon angekündigt habe
und zwar bin ich in einer kooperation
mit rewe und für delphi an und wir haben
so ein gewinnspiel gestartet
ich werde nächstes mal nämlich eine
richtig leckere philadelphia torte
kreieren und ihr dürft dann für mich
abstimmen
und es gibt auch noch andere torten und
wer für mich abstimmt und wenn meine
torte dann gewinnt dann gibt es nämlich
einen tollen gewinnen und zwar gibt es
einmal die kitchenaid es an die hier
hinten und einmal den mixa so wie hier
im blau ich glaube nur in anderen farbe
das weiß ich nicht ganz genau auf jeden
fall dürfte dann für die torte abstimmen
kommt dann eben in den lostopf und dann
wird das ganze eben per losverfahren
gezogen und ich würde mich natürlich
freuen wenn ihr da alle mit macht und
für meine torte abstimmt ich werde etwas
richtig tolles einfangen lassen und
hoffe dass euch die idee dann auch
gefällt und werdet ihr euch dann alle
informationen unten in form einer
infobox schreiben ich lade euch auch
jetzt schon mal den link unten mit rein
und da könnte dann auch alles nachlesen
auf jeden fall freue ich mich schon auf
die nächste torte die wird nämlich
ziemlich lecker vor allem mit sehr schön
sommerlich und ja ich freue mich schon
drauf
wir sehen uns dann bis dann